[Music]
are you doing today they're an excellent
first of all I want to thank you so much
for coming in I have so many things I
want to talk to you about but before we
get started the only reason we get to be
here at the Toronto International Film
Festival is because of sponsors want to
give a huge thank you to Nordstrom
Canada for being the great sponsor
helping us cover TIFF so a huge thank
you
Thank You Julie thank you for coming in
today thank you for having me so the
reason I'm talking to you today is from
my Zoey and before we go any further 99%
of the people watching us will have not
seen the movie yet so do you mind
how have you been describing the film to
friends and family it's a drama but
which is which has a bit of a twist to
it and also that is not kind of built
like a drama I I wanted to do a drama
that because of the subject matter which
is quite dark about a couple separating
and some some kind of a dramatic event
happening in their life etc and then a
complete third act that I think I go and
explore different you know what I'm not
the very very good like I've got a
couple of legs to describe this film I
think you know it's maybe we're gonna
get you media training sitting there
promise no but it's I think I wanted to
make a drama that's not at all a
melodrama and where the pace moves
almost like a thriller and I wanted to
explore this genre which is not a genre
really because it's it's kind of a it's
kind of an unusual film because III
talked about people but at the same time
I go into a sci-fi kind of world as well
I mean like I don't want to spoil
anything but I think that one of the
things you deal with in the third act
kind of has to be talked about or do you
not want to talk about it because you
don't want to talk about it keep it a
little shorter yes but it's definitely
something that's out of the ordinary and
doesn't I know what you're saying and I
will avoid saying anything specific I
will say one of the things that I really
appreciated about your movie is that you
are you have merged
- Jean Rah's and it's a little bit I
don't want to say science fiction
because it's right on the cusp of
happening if not already happening
with a realistic human drama about you
know two people getting a divorce and a
kid and the whole thing so um I guess
let me start with the back let me go way
back and say where'd the idea come from
like do you remember where this thing
came from you know it it it's you know
ideas for me they they come they stir
for years and years and years and years
so I think the first time I started
thinking the first spark was from a
discussion I had with Christophe
Kozlowski in the early 90s oh yeah yeah
no I know about fate and Parenthood and
I wasn't a parent yet so I didn't really
know what it was in the film it was just
a tiny spark okay about fate because he
was obsessed with fate and I'm obsessed
with fate and I'm a whatever and and
basically we you know I I let it go for
years and then when I became a parent to
me the whole story became obvious and
the sci-fi aspect was always there
because it's a to me I wanted also the
film to be a little bit of an allegory
of the pain that people go through
during child custody battle but for it
to translate to the real pain I needed
to go much further than a realistic film
sure because the pain is not just oh you
know you lose part of your child once in
a while at the pain to me and my
understanding of child custody and
losing your child part time the pain had
to be expressed somehow and that's how
this film was born basically the pain
the people are going through and the
madness the people are going through is
really more representative to me of a
real child custody battle than it is it
was realistic you know what I mean what
it felt like when I was watching it I'm
like well this feels very real and then
the thing like I'm in I really I don't
want to spoil anything but the thing
that I thought you did a great job of is
you are just which again I will not
spoil is that you are talking about
something in the movie that I think
could be happening right now and it's
not it's right on the cusp so I am
curious about like how much
you research all that a ton John and
throughout the years things evolved
obviously because it went very fast on
that subject matter scientifically but
what happened is that the way I built
the the film was three very distinct
distinct act the first act is a reality
that everyone knows a separation right
more or less everyone knows that or they
knew someone that's been through that
right was a kid then you go into the
second act which is a reality that
happens to some people unfortunately but
that is not a very common reality which
is the second act with the accident and
stuff and then the third act I went into
a reality that's not yet a reality and
that no one knows of so unexplored but
because I went through stages into you
know kind of like in a very realistic
setting you kind of come to this sci-fi
element without really feeling it as a
sci-fi element do you know what it
really it was essential to bring people
because there is no ethnic conversation
when you make a sci-fi film one where
everyone is a robot because you're like
okay everyone's a robot so whatever you
know what I mean
but when you go into a sci-fi film and
suddenly it becomes there's a human
element to it then you can have a
conversation about the ethics of all
this well that's the thing and again
it's it's this is a very tricky
interview because I don't want to review
right yet totally I will just say that
one of the things everyone's a ghost the
thing that I commend you on is that
you're dealing with you're asking a
question that I think a lot of at some
point people are going to be asking and
so anyway that's all I can say about
that and without going any further it's
complicated yeah totally but I guess my
next thing is how bad how much would you
be mad at me if I spent the rest of the
interview just talking about red no I'm
kidding I'm not going to bring up you
know I'm joking around but okay you've
worked with some very talented directors
when did you know earlier in your career
that you wanted to write direct III
wrote my first screenplay I was 15 years
old so I have done nothing with my life
no no but listen between the time I
wrote that first screenplay and wrote
five others and then I directed my first
film I was 36
so I spent 21 years just trying like a
miserable idiot in Hollywood dealing
with you know Hollywood of the times
before now you know and like all the
[ __ ] you had to deal with it as a
young actress and a young actress
wanting to be a director was like horror
you know like literally horror so you
know I was like constantly you know
fighting back and because I'm not you
know this kind of person to cave in the
system you know so I'm not gonna get
into it but you know like I'm really not
that kind of person you know and so it
was very complicated it was a very
complicated 21 years of waiting between
the time and it wasn't easy after
because even though two days in Paris
made everyone rich in an indie version
of rich it it really what didn't make my
life easier afterwards you know it's
like you know I don't want to say it but
the truth is when you're a woman you
make a successful film it's a fluke
basically you know it's it's an accident
you know what I mean it's it's changing
its changing but 15 years ago it was
still an act no I do feel from the
outside and I am NOT an expert but I do
feel from the outside that there it
seems like things are changing yes yes
it is it is it is now it's like people
they're actually you know considering me
for films and you know it's not it's not
something like people look at me and
they take my notes on the screenplay and
then they say goodbye and they hire a
commercial director or something you
know what I mean it's like you know it's
it's basically there they take me a
little seriously more seriously so I'm
curious with my Zoe how tough was it
after the film's you've made how tough
was it to get the financing or was it
let me start with that it was probably
the hardest film to get financing for
and I probably had 2/3 of the budget in
the end to shoot the film and it was
really really really tough but like
tough like a nightmare because of the
subject matter
because I'm mixing to genre sure because
it's an it's it's unusual to makes this
to
genre a lot of times people are looking
for something that's easy to market
exactly and it's it's in a way it it I
believe it's only things that are out of
the box that are actually easier to
market because it's something different
so it's actually exciting for me I only
want to see films that are exciting I
don't want to see the film that I saw
the last week you know what I mean I
want to see something different but when
people finance films that's not how they
think they think let's do something
that's how I got two days in Paris
finance actually my first film I had
just done before a sunset and I said
okay American boy French girl in Paris
so like this everyone feels safe
sure okay so I treat people and I made a
very different film but I treat people
into financing my film basically for
this one it was harder to trick people
so I had to present a screenplay and and
it was it was a hard one to pull off I
mean I have to say I was constant I had
I lost money a week before from some
crazy finance years you know who like
completely insane
you know who suddenly pulled up but
sometimes you have you know I ended up
with great finances in the end but the
journey was six years of living hell I
made other films in between to make a
living otherwise I'd be you know on the
street right now because really I'd be
on this also you bet you've had this for
a while this idea oh yeah I mean I wrote
the screenplay after my son was born ten
years ago so it's been ten years of
struggle yeah and yes I made other films
I mean I have to you know of course to
feed the family but I mean it's like you
know it's I it was my project that I was
carrying and and struggling to make and
all doors got slammed in my face I mean
it was like such a nightmare so I'm very
thankful for the film to be here once I
want to say a big thank you to the
financed ears whoever they are because
you made a really good movie or gave
money to a good movie so thank you thank
you yeah you have to tell them be take
risks a little bit because sometimes
it's not the end of the world
100% so I guess I have to ask you do you
have a lot of unproduced screenplays
sitting in the desk or are you one of
these like let me let me do that
yes I'm gonna talk about the ones that
when you were 15 I mean no no the one 15
the 1 15 and until my first film I even
don't even mention them okay so that's
like five screenplays that I'll never
make you know whatever but but there's
many others that I wrote since that you
know people read them they're like oh
it's so good
and then sure but I but I don't want to
be in it like okay but I didn't feel the
character but it's not my kind of film
let me ask you this if you if you get
one of the unproduced screenplays
produced tomorrow
what script what what's the movie and
what's it about probably it would be
actually a sort of a comedy it could be
a comedy about about the pioneer of
Hollywood but a very very funny kind of
a mix of Indiana Jones meets the artist
kind of thing does it have a title it's
called a dazzling display of splendor
okay we have now you know for anyone
watching anybody who wants to put a
little money in right exactly what does
it mean to be a we're at the Toronto
Film Festival what does it mean to be
part of this festival with your film I
think it's a wonderful festival and also
I'm very happy to be part of this
platform selection because I feel those
are really I mean over the years that
it's been their platform selection I've
seen really really interesting different
kind of work and I feel this is really
the you know the heart of a festival is
when films are picked because the
director of the festival actually really
loved the films and there are different
kind of films you know sure it's it's
kind of the essence of what a Film
Festival should be about and I really
feel proud to be in it I I also want to
give a thank you to 10th for thank you -
definitely so we've been asking everyone
coming through a few of the same
questions because we're gonna do what we
call a supercut so I'm gonna ask you a
few were the same okay it's a round of
Collider most memorable do you remember
your most memorable festival premiere
you know it's not funny and it's not
good
but fluid a civil premiere for my films
oh no for just in general for any film
that you've been out of like a premiere
of at a festival like the one that
really stands out listen it was my film
actually it was one of my film and it
was really depressing I I the first 10
minutes had no sound that's why I'm
gonna go on the tech morning the first
10 minutes had no sound and I would have
all didn't know there was a voiceover
explaining what we're gonna talk about
some no one had any idea of what was
going on and then I was at a weird
period of my life my mom was dying and I
had just give birth to my son so I had
breast milk I was milking and crying and
and and and my yeah it was one of the
most horrifying day of my life and of
course on top of it I come back to Paris
I I see my mom dying two days later and
and then I get an email a bunch of
critics hated the film so I was like I
was like okay but actually the bad
critics were kind of like I remember
laughing because I was like you know
what else can you do right that is a
horrible crazy sad emotion you know it's
everything yeah not the story I was
expecting but it worked out I know most
memorable school moment do you tortured
by entire I'm not opening this door on
you cuz I know you're gonna have a bad
story Lord of the Flies 24/7 do you have
a memorable scene like you you've
obviously been part of so many movies
but is there a scene from one of the
films that really stands out to you
something that like you will just never
forget either love or no no a film that
you've been in oh yeah
no no I don't remember films of that
I've done I don't remember
no no I remember
no on my last film I remember shooting
this film in the glass waiting room with
Irish armitage where we have an argument
at the hospital sure
and I remember shooting that seemed very
much it stays in my head a lot because
it was very interesting feeling of
really being in it like I felt like I
was not an actress anymore or a director
I was just in the moment completely
completely this is my last thing for you
obviously like everyone I adore the
before sunrise trilogy do you think down
the road you guys all right do you think
you're done with that little thing or do
you think because Linklater just
announced he's doing this 20 year movie
that's musical so obviously he's still
planning long periods ahead yeah do you
think that you guys still have another
story down the road in another 10 years
well I don't say I think we've moved on
all our ways now and I think it's pretty
much it I mean the last email was kind
of a vague email regarding a possibility
but it didn't really make sense um no I
don't think I don't think so no I don't
think so because I personally think it's
a perfect trilogy yeah yeah I love them
but I never thought they could like
every time you guys made a sequel I'm
like oh please don't [ __ ] it up
and each time it was so good but you
know I think are people interested in
raid ready because I'm not even sure
those guys are to have a point of view
of a 50 year old woman oh you know are
people interested in that because sadly
I have a feeling that you know I
actually there is no voice no right I
actually think that if there's anyone
who can pull it off and this my last
last thing is it's you guys because
people are so invested in these
characters and I think that they've been
so you're saying there's no voice for a
50 year old woman no I'm saying there is
but only for those characters no I'm
saying to you that it listen it's it's
gonna be tough
I'm not trying to get myself buried here
look it's hard it's hard to tell those
stories and let's not
because the truth is I'm really actively
working at changing this idea that a
woman after 50 has nothing to offer
because I think it's really really
screwed up and I feel it and I see it
and I I think it's [ __ ] first of all
I agree it's not true and you know but I
feel it like for years it was that way
and I think it needs to change but I
don't know if those guys are Richard is
doing is 20 years thing Ethan is you
know doing all these films I'm doing my
stuff you know we're all doing our own
stuff so for me I think that obviously
you guys have made a perfect trilogy and
I think that the only way to do another
one is if you have a story if we have
something to say that makes sense yes
and and yeah and that you know those two
characters of a voice a real voice yes
realism and some four hundred one
hundred percent I'm saying that I would
watch it just based on the trust you got
you know what you guys have done but
anyway we're uh whatever happens happens
yeah yeah we don't know yet you know the
truth is we're completely we don't
really know and everything up as a fan
and he's got injuries yeah yet but note
everyone watching I hope you see my Zoey
when you can see it if you're at TIFF
well you people are gonna watch this
after TIFF so eventually you'll be able
to see my Zoey I recommend it thank you
so much it has no UN's distribution yet
so that doesn't matter it will
eventually be oh really I'm very
convinced okay good that's good no I
really am but anyway thank you again to
Nordstrom Canada for being a great
sponsor Julie thank you so much for
coming in thank you so appreciate it
thank you thank you note we're done